[Aplausos]
[Música]
para muchos japón sigue siendo todo un
misterio y no os penséis que es porque
este sea el país donde pasear a los
perros en can el coche o ir a tomar café
a lugares llenos de gatos sea algo
normal para nada haberse convertido en
uno de los países más ricos y más
desarrollados del mundo y contar con la
esperanza media de vida más alta de todo
el planeta en un territorio superpoblado
y con escasos recursos naturales sigue
siendo algo que no deja de sorprendernos
pero amigos espera fundamento porque
japón no siempre fue la potencia
económica que conocemos hoy todo lo
contrario hasta mediados del siglo 19
este país estaba bajo un sistema
político y económico que se parecía
mucho a la europa de la edad media
por aquel entonces japón era un
territorio pobre atrasado cerrado al
mundo y con una sociedad fuertemente
estratificada ahora bien la pregunta es
cómo se produjo el gran cambio cómo
logró este país pasar de ser una pobre
economía rural a convertirse en toda una
potencia industrial
[Música]
fue todo producto de la influencia y la
ayuda de los eeuu tras la segunda guerra
mundial o fue acaso el resultado de un
plan minuciosamente diseñado por el
gobierno queridos amigos de visual
político podemos decir que en todo este
proceso hubo dos grandes etapas la
primera de la que hablaremos en este
vídeo se inicia hace precisamente 150
años con la llamada reinstauración male
150 años si estamos de aniversario la
segunda etapa de la que hablaremos en un
próximo vídeo así que ya sabéis no
olvidéis suscribiros al canal tuvo su
inicio al finalizar la segunda guerra
mundial pero dicho esto arranquemos con
esta historia vamos allá
no
la restauración meiji
hace 150 años la restauración meiji de
1868 terminó con el dominio que tenían
los tocaba un clan que durante más de
250 años ni más ni menos desde mil 603
prácticamente habían suplantado al poder
del emperador y se habían convertido en
los grandes señores de japón
hablamos de un largo período durante el
cual japón permaneció aislado de todo
contacto con el exterior algo que al
final terminó provocando que mientras
muchos países occidentales se lanzaban a
la industrialización japón se quedará
relegado con unas estructuras sociales
políticas y económicas más parecidas a
la edad media que a los tiempos modernos
japón era una sociedad feudal dominada
por señores de la guerra y que durante
ni más ni menos que catorce siglos se
había comportado como una especie de
estado vasallo del imperio chino
vamos muy diferente al japon que
conocemos hoy hablamos de un país que
llegó a prohibir el uso de sus puertos
por parte de extranjeros para evitar que
su influencia terminara contaminando la
cultura y las tradiciones locales claro
que eso también terminó con el comercio
y con cualquier posibilidad de que sus
rígidos estamentos políticos
evolucionaron al compás de los tiempos
esta fue la situación hasta que en 1853
una moderna flota de los eeuu llegó a la
bahía de tokio con una misión y un
mensaje o las autoridades japonesas
aceptaban y permitían el comercio o se
tendrían que atener a las consecuencias
[Música]
y los barcos a vapor rompen el descanso
de los halcones del pacífico' con solo
cuatro barcos bastan para hacernos
perder el sueño en las noches poema
japonés que hace referencia a los barcos
norteamericanos que llegaron al país en
1853 evidentemente ante una moderna
flota de guerra tecnológicamente
avanzada poco podían hacer las atrasadas
instituciones japonesas así que no les
quedó más remedio que aceptar y comenzar
la apertura
es amigos o el principio del fin del
régimen de los tocaba en pocos años
asqueados por la más que palpable
pérdida de soberanía por la humillación
de sentirse un país pobre e incapaz y
ante la experiencia de haber conocido el
ocaso del imperio chino los samuráis
unos samuráis por cierto mucho más
modernos que los que suelen salir las
películas se hicieron con el control y
restablecieron en japon imperial
hablamos de la conocida como
restauración meiji que contra todo
pronóstico lanzó al japon a los brazos
de un amplio programa de reformas y
cambio en prácticamente todos los campos
al fin y al cabo queridos amigos ante la
enorme superioridad tecnológica
económica y militar de las potencias
occidentales la mejor forma de preservar
la soberanía de japón no era otra que
tomar nota e impulsar el desarrollo del
país y sabéis que dicho y hecho en pocos
años a japón no lo reconocería ni los
propios japoneses estos son los pasos
que siguió un país para dar el salto
desde la edad feudal al mundo moderno
atentos a nivel político se terminó con
muchas de las viejas instituciones y se
introdujo un poder judicial
independiente un poder legislativo
bicameral y un moderno sistema de
prefecturas para gobernar las diferentes
regiones del país
los viejos impuestos sobre la venta de
arroz fueron sustituidos por un impuesto
a la tierra lo cual tuvo dos grandes
ventajas
primero facilitó el cálculo de los
ingresos que cada año tenía el gobierno
al fin y al cabo la cantidad de tierra
no cambia como si cambia cada año la
producción de arroz lo que permitió por
ejemplo diseñar financiar y construir
muchas infraestructuras y segundo obligó
a determinar con exactitud la
titularidad de la tierra
estableciendo para ello un moderno
sistema de derechos de propiedad
[Música]
pero esto no fue todo conscientes de lo
importante que era el conocimiento y las
nuevas tecnologías
en 1872 apenas cuatro años después de la
restauración meiji se estableció ya un
sistema de educación primaria universal
y en unos pocos años se había creado el
instituto de tecnología de tokio y la
universidad de tokio y por supuesto
además de todo lo que hemos visto se
impulsó la apertura de japón por ejemplo
se atrajeron expertos y profesionales
extranjeros para que transmitirán sus
conocimientos y muchos estudiantes
japoneses fueron becados para estudiar
tanto en europa como en los eeuu
el resultado de todo este proceso amigos
es que en tan solo 50 años japón logró
realizar su propia revolución industrial
esto fue un tercio del tiempo que le
costó a europa
de esta forma durante las siguientes
décadas el japón continuó con su proceso
de despegue y cambio y fue también
cuando empezó a extender su influencia a
países vecinos como corea china rusia o
taiwán en 1902 además firmó un acuerdo
de amistad con gran bretaña acuerdo que
no sólo impulsó su industria sino que
cuando llegó la primera guerra mundial
japón pudo aprovecharse para convertirse
en un importante proveedor e impulsar
aún más su economía durante estos años
muchos emprendedores japoneses se
hicieron millonarios
ya sea por un motivo o por otro al final
cuando los países impulsan el comercio
todas las partes suelen obtener
beneficios mister donald trump tome nota
pero amigos así es como llegamos a 1926
el año donde da comienzo la época más
tenebrosa del japón' atentos
[Música]
la economía de guerra
en 1926 el año en el que el emperador
hirohito llegó al trono donde por cierto
permaneció hasta 1989 el caso es que a
partir de este preciso momento en la
década de los años 20 japón comienza a
profundizar en su perfil más bélico en
1931 las tropas niponas ocuparon la
provincia china de manchuria donde no
sólo cometieron una enorme cantidad de
crímenes sino que también sería uno de
los desencadenantes de las tensas
relaciones entre japón y la mayor parte
de las potencias occidentales
además desde la llegada al poder de
hirohito el gobierno comenzó a impulsar
la industria de la guerra hasta tal
punto que en 1931 mientras las tropas
invadían manchuria el gobierno japonés
autorizó e impulsó la creación de
carteles entre las grandes compañías
especialmente entre la industria pesada
es decir aquella relacionada con el
acero la construcción de barcos
maquinarias camiones etcétera etcétera
de esta forma el gobierno instaba a las
grandes empresas a ponerse de acuerdo
para hacer crecer la producción lo más
rápido posible al tiempo que limitaban
la entrada de nuevos competidores
[Música]
y no sólo eso durante los siguientes
años el gobierno además inyectó mucho
capital hasta convertirse en como
propietario de muchas de estas compañías
todo mientras el gasto militar no paraba
de crecer
por supuesto esta masiva intervención
del gobierno en la economía tuvo
consecuencias las pequeñas empresas
fueron arrasadas y casi todas las
industrias civiles fueron cerradas mucho
antes de los bombardeos de los eeuu
durante la segunda guerra mundial las
consecuencias de esta economía de guerra
no sólo fueron un gobierno más
autoritario y una mayor influencia de
los militares lo que al final acabó
desembocando en la guerra sino también
el empobrecimiento general de los
japoneses
[Música]
claro había que producir material
militar no bienes que mejorar la vida de
las personas en el día a día más fusiles
y menos máquinas de coser menudo éxito
al final todos mucho más pobres
[Música]
y es que sabéis que esto no es nada
extraño la historia nos enseña que las
políticas militaristas suelen hacer de
oro impulsar el poder de una élite a
cambio de empobrecer a la mayoría amigos
el caso es que al final como todos
sabemos al terminar la segunda guerra
mundial japón no solo era un país
derrotado sino que su economía estaba
destrozada y los japoneses habían
retrocedido décadas décadas en lo que
respecta a su nivel de vida
todo ello por supuesto además de la
tragedia de haber perdido más de tres
millones de vidas durante el conflicto
tres millones de vidas
[Música]
ahora bien puede que alguno de vosotros
esté preguntando pero qué ocurrió una
vez terminada la guerra como logro japón
convertirse en pocos años en toda una
potencia amigos eso lo veremos en un
próximo vídeo aquí en visual político de
momento en este ya hemos visto cómo
japón dio el gran salto y paso de la
edad media al mundo moderno si te ha
resultado interesante este vídeo dale a
like y no olvides suscribirte a visual
política visual política y también al
canal de nuestros amigos de bali school
que están preparando muchas cosas
interesantes si te gusta el mundo la
inversión pásate por allí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]